this is the vanderbilt dynasty once the
richest family in the world and there's
a reason why you haven't heard much
about them you see unlike the
rothschilds and rockefellers today the
vanderbilts are pretty much unknown they
don't own any big businesses they don't
donate to universities anymore and they
don't have any skyscrapers named after
them
but once upon a time the vanderbilt
family once had more money than there
was in the us treasury over 200 million
dollars today that would be worth around
400 billion dollars beating out today's
richest dynasty the walmart dynasty buy
a long shot
their patriarch cornelius vanderbilt had
turned a 100 loan into a hundred million
dollar fortune in just 66 years making
him one of the wealthiest historical
figures of all time
but fast forward just 88 years basically
fast forward just one lifetime and not a
single living vanderbilt is a
millionaire not even one of them has a
million dollars to their name
after not even a hundred years and that
2.7 billion dollars in today's money is
gone the vanderbilt dynasties fall from
grace is a story of rags to riches greed
kids being born into money and power
that they didn't earn and learning just
how easy it is to lose it all
while you've been watching this video
your paycheck became worth almost eight
percent less that is the real impact of
inflation on your earnings but instead
of just accepting it and blaming
washington or the fed who you have no
control over you gotta take the power
back into your own hands that's why when
i did some research i came across a
fintech startup valued at one billion
dollars called masterworks and what
they're doing is pretty cool masterworks
lets you invest in blue chip arts an
asset class that saw a price
appreciation of 23 on average when
inflation is above 3
like it is right now the team of art
experts analyzes over 60 000 data points
to find trending artists with high
potential for growth they then purchase
the paintings by these artists and then
after that masterworks members can
purchase shares representing an
investment in those artworks on their
platform
since their inception in 2017
masterworks has successfully offered and
sold two paintings from his collection
each realizing a net annual gain in
excess of thirty percent per work
although this is not an indication of
masterworks overall performance and past
performance is not indicative of future
results it's still pretty cool so join
over 300 000 other members on the
platform by using my special link below
to get priority access so pause the
video and click the link below to get
priority access to masterworks now
thanks to masterworks for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
cornelius vanderbilt was born in a time
where entire industries were being born
for the taking oil railways and for
cornelius it was shipping at 11 years
old he dropped out of school to help on
his parents farm in staten island new
york city a few years later he decided
that life on the farm wasn't for him and
there was one thing he always wanted a
boat of his own back in the 1800s the
new york harbor was filled with men
sailing up and down the canals making
money transporting passengers and cargo
and cornelius won it in he wanted a
taste of real money so before his 16th
birthday he made a deal with his mom he
would borrow a hundred dollars equal to
around two thousand three hundred
dollars a day and in exchange he would
turn an eight-acre overgrown field into
a healthy cornfield his mom thought it
was impossible but she underestimated
cornelius he got all his friends to help
out and true to his word on the day of
his 16th birthday the job was done so he
took that hundred dollar loan and set
off to the harbor to buy a boat he was
so eager to be recognized and respected
for his work that other sailors started
calling him the commodore for fun and
the nickname stuck so he started
transporting passengers for 18 cents a
trip and he made more money than he ever
dreamed of then came the advent of
steamships cornelius saw the writing on
the wall and jumped into the steamship
business within just a few years he had
turned his one boat company into an
entire fleet that rivaled the biggest
shipping company in new york cornelius
had finally made it big he was new money
but cornelius was a rough man he wasn't
educated he wasn't sophisticated he
didn't fit into high society so even
with his newfound riches none of the
upper class new yorkers wanted anything
to do with them so he went back home and
on the same farm where he had grown up
he built a giant mansion overlooking the
ships by the time cornelius turned 56 he
was the head of the largest shipping
empire in the world but it wasn't enough
he wanted more america was on the edge
of civil war investing now would be a
suicide mission so he did the
unthinkable around the same time
america's very first transcontinental
railroad was being built this railroad
would make transporting cargo and
passengers cheaper and faster than ever
and cornelius never to go half in on
anything sold every last ship he had and
invested everything into the railway his
gamble pays off by the end of the war he
was the richest man in america with a
net worth of 68 million dollars making
him a billionaire today by now cornelius
was 71 years old he needed to start
thinking about his family's future his
favorite son george had died in the war
now the only boys who were left were
william and cornelius jr neither of them
were any good at being businessmen but
he had to choose one so he settled for
the oldest william he would become the
heir to the entire vanderbilt fortune
[Music]
cornelius may have been an old man but
he was nowhere near the end of his
career when his competitor started
taking his customers he went on the
offensive first he tried negotiating
with them to make them pay a percentage
for every passenger they brought into
new york these young businessmen refused
there was no way they were gonna get
ordered around by such an old man but
there was only one problem they had
underestimated how far the commodore
would go to crush his rivals you see
cornelius vanderbilt owned the only rail
bridge into new york city all his
competitors were using it to move their
passengers and cargo so cornelius again
did something no one expected he put a
blockade on the bridge so none of his
competitors trains could get in or out
of new york every day they lost millions
of dollars with all the railroad
companies hemorrhaging money their
presidents started selling their shares
at record speeds they wanted to get
their money out before their stock
prices hit rock bottom the news reaches
wall street and triggers a major
sell-off cornelius tells his son to buy
up as many shares as he can buy
everything you can and voila cornelius
vanderbilt pulls out the first hostile
takeover in history in just a few days
cornelius vanderbilt had taken over his
biggest competitor and created the
largest single railroad company in
america
the commodore had became the undisputed
railroad monopolist he built statues of
himself in his honor and created a major
railway station bringing three major
railroads together he called it grand
central and grand central still stands
to this day as a symbol of the
vanderbilt legacy but then cornelius
dies at 82 years old his net worth stood
at 100 million dollars or 2.7 billion
today and almost all of it goes to his
disappointment of a son william billy
vanderbilt before he died cornelius
vanderbilt told his son any fool can
make a fortune it takes a man of brains
to hold on to it after it is made
[Music]
william billy vanderbilt was his
father's least favorite son after billy
got married his father has so little
patience for him that he sent him and
his wife to go live on a farm so they
wouldn't be there to bother him but then
cornelius's youngest and favorite son
died and suddenly the vanderbilt dynasty
needed a new heir someone to take the
reins when the commodore retired or died
whichever came first so billy was pulled
into the family business and when he
finally took over his dad's empire he
proved just how great of a businessman
he really was you see cornelius
vanderbilt always wanted more he wanted
more control more money more influence
but his son was nothing like that he was
okay with compromising and in the eight
years between his father's stuff and his
own billy doubled the family fortune
going from 100 million to 200 million in
just eight years he still summoned his
stake in new york central and invested
most of it into stable government bonds
he was never the money chasing kind of
guy his dad was all he wanted was to
live his life in peace and he hated
being the richest man in the world or at
least that's what he told everyone who
asked
at one point he was so tired of being
rich he told his friend quotes i would
not walk across the street to make a
million dollars end quotes owning a
railway was too much pressure and even
though he was good at it he had had
enough so when the time came for him to
choose an error he split the vanderbilt
fortune between his two sons
billy vanderbilt was the first and only
heir to grow the family fortune all his
kids and their kids they just took and
took and took and what they quickly
learned was that it might be difficult
to make a 5.8 billion dollar fortune in
today's money but a sure is easy to
spend its
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is alva vanderbilt wife of
cornelius's grandson william kissing
vanderbilt if he had to blame someone
for losing the vanderbilt family fortune
she would be a good place to start you
see back in the late 1800s in new york
your position in society was a big deal
at the time when alva married william
the vanderbilt family was not included
in the list of the 400 upper class new
york families the women who created the
list had no time for how unsophisticated
the vanderbilts were and billy didn't
care if the family was on the list or
not but alva did so she set out to
change that she wanted to feel accepted
by new york's upper class knobs and in
order to do that she hosted a massive
party to reintroduce the house of
vanderbilt to the world the party was
attended by a thousand people and cost
williams six million dollars in today's
money everyone attended and suddenly the
vanderbilts were in
but being accepted by new york's high
society meant keeping up with
appearances which meant alpha needed to
keep spending money she built a massive
home in the countryside another mansion
in new york she made william buy her a
500 000 yachts with her name on it it
was like keeping up with the joneses but
on a massive scale whatever money the
two vanderbilt brothers could add to the
family fortune alva made sure it was
quickly used up but at least they were
getting the respect they deserved
the problem was one she was spending
more than they were making and two it's
very easy to inflate your lifestyle but
it's very hard to cut back
but that didn't stop her and soon the
entire vanderbilt family got addicted to
the spending and money started flying
out of the vanderbilt's coffers at
record speeds
alva rubbed off on the whole family
while billy was still alive he took a
page out of her book and bought up an
entire block on fifth avenue to turn
into one big mansion for those that
don't know fifth avenue in new york city
is one of the most expensive shopping
streets in the world today luckily
billy's wife taught them out of it so
instead he built a couple of massive
mansions that filled the block anyway
when one vanderbilt child inherited 15.5
million dollars he celebrated by losing
70 000 on a single bet that same
grandson blew thousands on alcohol and
unsurprisingly died of liver disease the
third and fourth generation of
vanderbilts only knew how to do one
thing spend they bought houses all over
america traveled the world and did
everything they could to enjoy every
last sense the commodore and billy
vanderbilt had worked for the problem
was they never did anything to make more
money and at the time the world was
changing faster than the vanderbilt's
old railway business could keep up with
and as the years went by things only
went from bad to worse for them
[Music]
the early vendor bills had it easy their
industries had very little regulation
and taxes weren't such a big deal but by
the early 20th century the government
introduced estate taxes income taxes
gift taxes suddenly these taxes were
cutting into the millions the
vanderbilts had left then the great
depression hit and suddenly they had to
scramble to find new ways to support
themselves all the while no one did
anything to keep the money they already
had by the end of world war ii planes
and cars had taken over the royal
railroads used to play so the vanderbilt
family saw what was left of the stake in
new york central but they never
established new businesses or
investments to make their money work for
them instead they ended up spending
whatever they had left by the 1973
vanderbilt family reunion not even one
family member was a millionaire the only
other big name to come out of the family
was gloria vanderbilt's a popular
fashion designer and even then she told
her son there was no trust fund no
family fortune that son was anderson
cooper today cnn news anchor less than
150 years after the commodore died the
vanderbilt dynasty had lost it all
so next time you feel envious towards
rich kids or trust fund babies just
remember that being born into wealth can
be just as much of a curse as it is a
blessing
[Music]
you